So right now I live in Boston there on the
East Coast.
Many of my friends there who have been there
for a while they have a story.
They all remember the day that this happened.
On August 14, 02003, several states in the
American Northeast and Midwest
And part of Canada
Experienced what was then the second
biggest black out of all time in the world.
55 million people lost power.
Some of them lost power for up to a week.
And what could cause so much chaos?
Given that no foreign power has ever taken
down America's electric grid
Especially on this scale
Who was this master criminal
Who successfully launched an attack on our own infrastructure?
The culprit...
Was a tree!
It was a nice summer day
So people turned on their air conditioning
Which heated up the wires
And because metal expands when it's heated
That caused to wires to sag
And it sagged enough that a tree
In Ohio
Could reach that wire
And set it all on fire
Which is okay.
This is actually normal - this happens all
the time.
And this would usually result only in one
station, one power station being knocked out.
But due to a software bug, they couldn't send
an automated alert to its neighboring power stations
So it took its electric load and passed it
off to its neighboring power stations
Which caused THEM to overload
So they passed their load onto their neighbors which caused THEM to overload
Which created a vicious cycle that
swept throughout the entire Northeast
Causing...
A blackout.
This isn't the only example of something bad
cascading throughout an entire network.
For example, the 02008 Financial Crisis.
A handful of banks in the US made some bad
bets.
And then Greece burns.
That's because we're living in such a connected
economy - for better and for worse.
Or think about epidemics.
One patient zero, a little while later, millions
die.
That's because we're all really connected—again,
for better or for worse.
And underlying all these systems is something
called "attractors."
They're called attractors because they attract
the system towards different things.
In this case they all attract the system towards
failure.
So, imagine you have a ball on an oddly-shaped
hill.
And let's say that the left-right position
represents how good or bad something is.
So if the ball's way on the left, that's good,
none of the power stations have failed
And all the banks are still alive.
But if it falls all the way to the right,
that means that power stations have all failed
The banks are all bankrupt.
Also want to clarify that the up-down axis
is not good or bad, it's "stable" or "unstable."
So if a ball is really high up in the air,
it's pretty unstable.
But if it's down, grounded close to the earth,
it's pretty stable.
And now, stable and unstable, again, words
are terrible
They have positive and negative connotations
But here's the thing: here we have a good
but unstable situation.
And also a bad but very stable situation.
And these mountains are what we saw earlier:
reinforcing loops.
A ball on a hill.
So one reinforcing loop in the
power station example is: power station fails
It cascades on to the next ones.
Or: a bank fails, and that cascades on to
the next banks.
It keeps the ball rolling.
And the valleys, those correspond to balancing
loops.
Ball in the valley.
For example, for the power station example,
eventually you run out of power stations to make fail
And for banks, eventually you run out of banks
to make bankrupt.
So the ball stops at the bottom of that valley.
And these valleys are the attractors.
Because they attract the ball to a certain
point.
In this case, failure.
So now imagine you are standing next to this
ball, and you're a complete jerk so you push it a little bit
And with a little small nudge, it gets past
the tipping point, and then gravity takes over
The ball will clearly roll down the reinforcing
loop of the mountain and into the balancing loop
The valley, the attractor.
The Valley of Death.
And furthermore, you can see that if you were
to go down and actually be nice for once
And try to undo all your damage, it would take
you a lot more effort
Than what it took you to push the ball in the first place all the way down.
That's why a blackout can cascade in a few
hours, but fixing it took weeks.
Or why the recession can spread around the
globe in a few months but fixing it took
Well, we're still living through the consequences.